. I don't think it's going to surprise to
many people who are in our audience to hear
what I'm about to tell you.
But it has now been revealed that many of
the lawyers representing Donald Trump in his
Senate impeachment trial are Republican donors
to Republican senators currently in the Senate
who will be the ones voting to either convict
or acquit Donald Trump.
Now, this changes nothing about the reality
of the foregone conclusion that is Donald
Trump's acquittal in the Senate.
But the incredible contrast of this is that
there were some Republicans saying, you know,
Bernie and Warren should recuse themselves
from the entire Senate trial.
They shouldn't be allowed to vote on Trump's
impeachment conviction or acquittal because
Bernie and Warren and Klobuchar are running
for the democratic nomination.
They could potentially be facing Donald Trump
in the general, and it's a conflict of interest.
Now, they never actually make explicit what
kind of a conflict of interest it is.
I guess it's, they might vote to convict so
they don't have to face Trump in the general
or something like that.
But in any case, Democrats don't have the
votes to convict, so it's relatively moot.
But now we find out, wait a second.
The Senate majority leader, Mitch McConnell,
the top Republican in the Senate, who is involved
in running the trial, who's involved in setting
the rules for the trial?
Who's involved in deciding if and when?
There will be a debate about calling witnesses?
Mitch McConnell received campaign donations
from two of Donald Trump's lawyers.
Kenneth Starr, one of Donald Trump's lawyers,
donated the maximum, uh, in the past to, uh,
in, in the last year to Mitch McConnell and
has given more money to mention McConnell
in the past.
Robert Ray, another Trump lawyer, gave $5,600
to Mitch McConnell's Senate reelection committee.
We are also now learning that Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham, who will be voting on whether
to convict Trump, was in the loop himself
about the effort to find dirt on the Bidens
in Ukraine.
This is according to love Parness and now
indicted henchman of Trump's personal lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani.
It's like a game of clue.
So let me say that again.
One of the senators who will get to vote,
convict or acquit for Donald Trump was allegedly
in the loop the entire time.
About the effort to find dirt about the Bidens
in Ukraine to help Trump get elected in 2020
he will be voting okay.
We have to hear from Lev Parness.
I don't know if we will.
We have to hear from John Bolton.
I don't know if we will, but can there even
be a fair trial here?
We started with a trial that had as a foregone
conclusion, it's outcome the acquittal of
Donald Trump, likely by all 53 Republican
senators in the Senate.
Remember, you need 67 to convict a president
on impeachment in the Senate.
We had those same Republicans start to argue,
we don't even need witnesses.
That fight will happen in the Senate today.
Maybe it's already happening when senators
actually debate and vote on witnesses, but
half or nearly half of the Senate thinks it's
perfectly fine to have a trial without calling
material witnesses like John Bolton.
And now we find out that at least some of
the senators who will be voting were either
involved tangentially in the actions that
lead to impeachment seeking dirt and Ukraine
or have received campaign cash from the lawyers
representing Donald Trump.
Do you think that when Trump's team wants,
for example, no debate about witnesses until
after each side has presented and they've
donated to Mitch McConnell and Mitch McConnell
says he's coordinating everything with the
white house and then McConnell comes out and
says, Hey, you know what?
I agree.
Let's not talk about witnesses until the trial
is almost over.
Are we supposed to believe that everything
is on the up and up?
It is mind bending corruption.
There are millions of Americans just not paying
attention because they have busy lives.
I understand it.
They're earning a living and there is mind-bending
corruption going on.
There are millions of Americans who know what's
going on and don't care because they either
love anything that will vindicate Donald Trump
as they see it, even a false vindication,
and then of course there are simply ignorant
people who are unable to really put the facts
together and build a picture of what is going
on.
They're in on it one way or the other.
Lindsay Graham doesn't want witnesses because
he was in on it.
McConnell doesn't want witnesses because Trump's
lawyers donated to him and they don't want
it and he's the guy who says, I am going to
be in complete coordination with the white
house on the impeachment trial.
It's a crude analysis, but we're often finding
that the simplest explanation for the facts
is often a pretty good one and it's a very
ugly, ugly reality.
Let me know what you think about these latest
revelations.
We are just two days from the David Pakman
Sunday birthday membership special.
It's my birthday on Sunday.
We are going to do an email blast to everybody
who signs up for our mailing list.
You do that, you do that on our website, David
pakman.com it's really easy to just type in
your email address.
You don't need to email me saying, please
put me on the mailing list.
You can sign up for the mailing list on the
website on Sunday.
You will get an email with very specific instructions
as to how to take advantage of this crazy
whacked out, delusional discount.
My mom called me and said, I caught wind of
this discount.
Are you okay?
Are you feeling okay because the discount
seems out of control.
Get on the mailing list.
You'll be notified someday